- Hey, this is Ronny Chieng.
- I'm Roy Wood Jr., and this
is Build Yo Squad.
"Yo" or "your"?
- Uh, I—that's your call.
- Yo squad.
- OK.
We're picking the best basketball team with
athletes from other sports, and we've got
$15 to do it.
- That's right.
- Roy, thanks for dressing up for this.
- Well, you know, I do what I can.
- OK.
- These are some of the best athletes in
their respective sports.
- OK.
- None of them basketball. Which one of
these athletes has the skills that
transfer over to basketball?
- Um...
- Gimme Terrell Owens as a—
- Wait, aren't you going like this?
You're gonna go one—
- No, we, we can pick from any category.
It's just gotta equal $15.
- OK.
So your No. 1 pick is Terrell Owens for $3?
- Out of anybody on this board,
I believe Terrell Owens best has the
skills that translate to basketball. Good
height, big hands, wide reach.
- That's everybody on this board.
- Not everybody.
It's either T.O. or Deontay Wilder.
That's my starting center.
One of these two.
- But he's gonna, he's gonna wear 50 pounds
of costume
every game.
- He wore a suit and his legs was tired.
So what? Can he hoop is the question, Ronny.
- Yeah, that is. Can he hoop? Just because he's
wearing a durag doesn't mean he can hoop, OK?
- Yes, it does.
That's exactly what it means.
- This guy's a prototypical diva wide receiver.
You don't want this guy on your team, man.
- OK, then you pick a center.
- OK.
- Let's start with a center.
- Center, uh,
I'm gonna go with Bo Jackson here, man.
- I think you're bein' cheap. He's a dollar.
You're bein' cheap.
- And also he's a dollar is a bonus.
Yes, but he's the—
- Prime Bo Jackson—
- Prime Bo Jackson.
- Was 6'3".
- Yeah, 6'3" center in every game I played..
- You play small ball like the Rockets now?
Is that what you're doin'?
- Dude, I played center in every game I played.
I'll give you Bo, but not as a center.
So what, do you want Bo—
you want Bo to play the 3?
- OK, power forward. He'll play power forward. Bo Jackson—
-  OK, fine. Put the dollar down. Put the dollar down. We'll
pay up for Bo.
- Am I actually supposed to put a dollar on
the floor?
- Yes, we have to. Don't you have $15?
- Yeah, but I'm
- supposed to throw it on the floor?
- Yeah, man. Let's make it rain.
So, Bo Jackson is our 3.
- Should I do it like that or—
- Just gimme that.
There we go.
All right, so we got our 3.
Bo Jackson's our 3.
- Yeah.
- Where do you wanna go next?
- Who's the tallest guy in this thing?
Jimmy Graham?
He actually played basketball.
This guy was a basketball star.
- That's a lotta money.
That's a lotta money for Jimmy Graham.
- You get what you pay for, man.
- I would—since you're not gonna let me pick either
of the two tall black guys, I would go Tyson Fury
as a center.
He's the new Laimbeer.
He's Bill Laimbeer 2.0.
- That's not a good thing.
- He's gonna get in there.
He's got reach.
He's gonna get people off.
You saw him box out like this.
He's a better deal than Jimmy Graham.
- How? This guy played basketball, like, at a
Division I level. Was it Division II?
- He's $5.
- OK, fine.
You want, you want, you want a enforcer on
the team.
OK, fine, then you—
- We need a center.
- Didn't this guy just beat this guy?
- But the only reason he beat that guy is cuz
this guy wore a stupid outfit and popped an
ear drum.
He's wearin' a durag, Ronny.
OK, fine.
We'll go with the durag.
- Thank you. Deontay Wilder.
We got a center.
We got our 3.
- Yeah.
Uh, point guard.
Here's my pitch.
- OK.
- Simone Biles. She can take the ball
and do flips. You know that stuff you saw
in "Space Jam"?
- Is that legal? That's And1 stuff, though.
That doesn't translate.
- Yeah.
- Gymnasts are traditionally short.
They're muscular.
They got ups.
- Dude, did you see how high she flipped?
- Yes.
- Can you imagine her doing that in game?
That's crazy.
She's your best, best in-game.
dunker of all time.
- If you hip check her, she'll flip
and fly right out into the crowd.
- Uh, I think she's harder to hip check than you
think, man.
- OK.
I like Simone, but we gotta pair her with
somebody that can set the picks and come
off the ball for her.
- Who here has the most money?
- Let's flip it around.
Make one of the soccer stars the 1.
Let them run point.
Simone comin' off the ball—
- Yeah.
- Doin' the flips.
- What is a forward in soccer but a point guard?
Comin' down the field, seein' the vision,
seein' what's goin' on, reading what the
defense is doing and figuring out where
to distribute.
And these two are master distributors.
Alex Morgan or Rapinoe.
- I don't like any soccer
players for basketball, just because I
feel like they don't—
- They literally dribble.
- Yeah, but not the hands.
- That's literally what the maneuver is called
in soccer is dribble.
- It's like watching people play with their
left hand. Like, it's—
- So, because they never used their hands before in athletics—
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Soccer players are out?
- I think so.
Yeah.
- You wanna go Serena?
- Is this the longest time
this segment has ever gone?
- [Producer:] It's tight, yeah.
- Oh, f--k.
- OK, we'll tighten up.
- OK.
- Let's pay for Simone.
Let's just start right there.
- OK.
Let's pay for Simone.
- Simone.
OK. That's $2 for Simone.
- She's in. We'll figure out where she flips—
- Now how much money do we have?
- And who's gonna pass the ball to her.
My point is, she can't flip and have the ball.
We gotta pass her the ball off the flip
- Four, five, six, seven, eight, nine dollars for—what?
Two players?
- Yeah, we need two more players.
- Yeah, this dude is all—this guy played, played
basketball at a collegiate level. It's literally ridiculous
to not pick the guy.
He's tall.
He's a pro athlete, and he played at a high level.
- Let him run the 4.
- OK, thank you.
One, two, three, four, five.
You need a—
- So now we need a shooting guard.
- Shooting guard.
How much we got? How much do we have?
- $4.
- $4 on a shooting guard.
- Yeah.
- OK, so Lamar or Russell Wilson?
- Let's go with Lamar.
He's a bit taller.
- All right, Lamar Jackson.
- Lamar Jackson.
- All right, pay up.
- Cool. Cool.
Here you go.
- I like this.
- Boom.
That's $15, and we solved nothing.
- That's right.
He's Ronny Chieng.
I'm Roy Wood Jr.
We just built our squad with yo squad,
our squad.
- A squad.
- Build your squad in the comments below,
and your squad will get trashed by our sqaud.
Get all of your election coverage on "The
Daily Show," Comedy Central. Weeknights
11/10 Central.